so Dirk gentle from
Germany
1828 can't move either t yes
I had that against him
before somehow I didn't get on well with it either
so
somehow I don't have a good memory
of the
game so I'm going to try a
different
variant that's rather unusual  But it's
not
uninteresting so he has
given up the 4. I'm
just trying to keep this pawn.
Yes, I don't see anything against it at the moment.
How is he supposed to get it back so easily? Knight
G4,
I make Bishop
D4 al or Knight G4 just hangs
D5
something like that now with A3 A3 bishop C5
B4 knight from
queen doesn't work at all or again B4
bishop from queen he can't
take I thought he can't
take again B
4 knight from queen bishop D2 just
a
piece or queen A4 chess  even
theoretically he also went
checker that even clearer checker checker A4 chess
bishop
[music]
D7 checker A4 chess runner D7 checker B4
bishop
B4 bishop D2 is perhaps even clearer
check
hm rook C8 I'm just thinking about it, that was
so clever rook
C8 rook C1 knight E4
hm knight plain E4 rook plain C1
matt H a bit a bit strange no
maybe you have to play the slightly crooked
Zuchspringer A2
well you're still standing a
bit cramped here for the
pieces
h well
check
so the knight takes the king E4
came
so
it's a bit  I would have concerns
now if he draws D4 he
even closes his eyes and now
he can take E4 then
tom8
somehow still looks a
bit uncomfortable he
has Irish passive
figures Z was one more of them but they
all stand
strangely well I
think he does  I have to take it more
or less now,
I only need a
few moves until I
've consolidated myself here, ugly but
necessary,
so yes, I've already seen that but
I wasn't sure Springer
E3 actually threatens nothing
great and can't go here  or
he would be
taken away straight away so so so
now things are slowly starting to look
good again
like knight D6
well black resign yes he
missed the chance with knight E4 I think
if he now takes knight E4
knight simply E4 to E8 and then F5
n  If I then cover somehow, I do
n't know, in any case it looks like
whether he might
win another pawn or something like that, in any
case, that's that's too
slow